on va garder la frange qui fait du
supplément de sécurité un petit clic qui
va faire la différence
retenu par un élastique ses adeptes du
bungee ont pratiqué du fitness en
musique
mais avec une amplitude démultipliée
mieux vaut quand même avoir un minimum
de prêts reçus car très vite coeur
muscles équilibre coordination et
souplesse sont sollicités toute
l'attention est au niveau de la ceinture
abdominale
non que le reste du corps on est
suffisamment aidé d'un port la nouvelle
afrique pour voir soulever le bas du
corps donc on a beaucoup de
sollicitations niveau du gainage c'était
aussi pour avoir un petit peu plus de
sensations et la fondation matrix la
sensation d'apesanteur
et puis ça permet aussi à certaines
personnes de pouvoir faire des choses
qu'il n'aurait jamais pu faire sans
l'élastique avoir les pompes explosif
sans les mains
les derbys avec les jeunes qui montent
les deux hôpitaux par exemple donc et
donc du coup on fait un travail un petit
peu plus dynamique avec des exercices
qu'on n'aurait peut-être pas pu faire
mais on a encore un impact au niveau du
système cardiovasculaire est encore plus
récents déjà une soixantaine de
pratiquants est venu tester cette
nouvelle discipline toujours plus
ludique et innovante les salles de sport
attire ainsi une clientèle variée
à 69 ans et une pêche d'enfer hélène
s'est fixé un défi s'est lancé en juin
prochain après son fils dans un saut à
l'élastique du haut d'un pont d'une
centaine de mètres
en attendant elle se teste et se prépare
je le sens bien parce que pour
l'élasticité du camp chez les jeunes
bonne chose pour le coeur vous faites
des efforts que vous ne ressentez pas
vouloir chanter pas les douleurs quand
est-ce que vous avez l'élastique qui
vous retient combien quand on sort de là
on se sent coupable alors j'étais une
personne très nerveuse comme tout le
monde le connaissait la météo je suis
zen et encore quand je sens qu'ici
encore plus jamais un côté fun zen mais
pas seulement
dans la salle aussi des sportifs a
conclu ils sont karatékas danseurs ou
athlètes et voit dans le bungee une
façon de compléter leurs enfants
spécifique au triple saut kandisha
s'élance à plus de 13 mètres à la
longueur sa dernière performance au
champion de france 6 mètres 33 alors ces
exercices en salle supporté par
l'élastique permettent de diminuer les
impacts au niveau des articulations qui
comptera vaillant surtout tu niques la
surface est moins dur donc pas encore
fait à beaucoup de répétitions sur une
se passe moins bien donc moins de moyens
de choc
donc mon un traumatisme pour les
articulations
et puis le doubs alors on faisait un
exercice yeux des fentes justement c'est
moi je souhaite en extension en saut en
longueur donc ça peut être justement un
exercice nous aider à travailler le
temps de suspension en l'air au final et
avec un peu de pratique c'est une
chorégraphie semi aériennes qui se
dessine en salle de sport avec à la clé
de nouvelles sensations à la découverte
de son corps dans un nouvel espace